foreign
we all have vulnerabilities
and weaknesses that somebody can exploit
where's Dan very sorry Mom
Karen
where is Jan I think all of us have
known
narcissists and Psychopaths and people
who we trust who take advantage of us
[Music]
the kind of loss of Innocence that's
depicted in this story is a particularly
horrific one
oh where's Dan
my name is Nick antonca I'm the writer
Creator showrunner of a friend of the
family
three four friend of the family is based
on the true story of the broberg family
whose daughter Jan was kidnapped
multiple times in the 1970s by the same
person
you know what you just call me b
asier than brother Birch told Anna and
the kids too to me this is a
psychological horror show
um this is a show about a a very normal
family who
encounter uh a monster wearing the face
of someone they love and Trust I am here
to escort a young lady to a piano lesson
and then to ride a horse
I wasn't expecting you be I think
there's been a misunderstanding
thought I heard your voice yeah you
thought right how was school pretty good
what happened to the brobergs is a slow
burn
um and so in order for the audience to
experience along with them the the show
needs to be a slow burn too you know if
you try and tell this story
dramatized in 90 minutes or two hours
the big events are so momentous and so
shocking it's like Whiplash but this
happened over six years so there was
time for normalcy to seep back in and
for people to kind of get comfortable
and for them to feel safe come home and
you go to school and go to bed and just
all these normal things are going on
it's it's not like
one thing after another
um that they were able to get back into
the rhythm of their lives and we wanted
the show to capture the sense of
normalcy and also the sense of waiting
and a sense of dread
um that's one reason it was so valuable
to have nine episodes to tell it
I'm Marianne we all have vulnerabilities
[Music]
and weaknesses that somebody can exploit
and and it's easier to take advantage of
those weaknesses
than you might think and I wanted to
better understand how that happened in
this case and I wanted to understand
what it felt like to live through this
experience over all those years
it's going to be a great day
I think all of us have known people who
we trust who
take advantage of us or who turn out to
be
not the person who we thought they were
while this story initially seems like it
might not be so relatable I think it
really is relatable I think everybody
can relate to that and it's a matter of
degree and a matter of scope
where's Danny more people than you want
to think have experiences with sexual
abuse or grooming or they know somebody
who does and I think the story is very
very relevant
I made him promise and be home by 6 30.
where are they
your allergy pill
look I can take out that water
I think that when a lot of people saw a
documentary abductive and plain sight it
was easy for them to judge the pro Birds
that's the easy reaction to have to
hearing this story you kind of can't
comprehend how this guy was able to do
the things that he did to his family and
how they made some of the decisions that
they made but when you understand the
the texture of their lives and the
context in which it happened and the
fact that like
95 of what was going on in their lives
was like normal and safe and only five
percent was suspicious and dangerous
that's how he kind of crept in and
insinuated himself you start to
understand how like the Frog was slowly
boiled proverbially they let all these
things kind of slip by until they were
so deep that they couldn't get out
you know the brobergs made as they say
every mistake in the book they weren't
stupid
um they lived in a time when their whole
Community was about
forgiveness and trust and love and
family and Brotherhood and those are the
values that this man this Predator
exploited to take their child when you
understand the context you can
understand how this came to to be
I just want to be worthy of your respect
bro bird yours and Marianne oh you are
you are worthy I mean every man has
worth in the eyes of the Lord
the kind of loss of Innocence that's
depicted in this story is a particularly
horrific one
there's also a loss of innocence for
the parents I mean everybody in this
story except for B is an innocent at the
beginning and the story of their lives
from 1972 to 1978 is the story of going
from
innocence to a tragic kind of experience
and
a wisdom and a knowledge in the sense
that trust has to be earned
and it will go out in public
that you are a sinful man
with a natural desires
[Music]
I've been unfaithful to you I've been
unfaithful to you
[Music]
with me
we developed the look of the show and
the Cinematic feel of the show
um with Eliza Hitman who directed the
pilot and all the other directors but
Eliza really set the look and we always
wanted it to feel authentically 70s
without feeling like a Nostalgia piece
so we looked at
films from the time that felt real but
still kind of felt modern
specifically Alice doesn't live here
anymore
Badlands the Sugarland Express those
were some of our cinematic reference
points and inspirations
Jan broberg was involved in the show
from day one as a producer on the show
and she was a consultant she was always
present and available we called her
after we had seen the documentary and
read her book which is what made me feel
like it was incredibly Rich dramatic
material that deserved Nine episodes and
an immersive kind of serialized
experience and from that day on we
talked to Jan constantly she came to the
writer's room we went to visit her in
person she was on set she read all the
scripts we sent her the episodes we went
to visit Jan and stayed with her we
attended Mormon Services
we were able to learn about their
Community
we wanted to portray them faithfully and
respectfully we also had a Mormon writer
on the show and a Mormon consultant on
set and Jan would always always go
through the scripts and tell us this
would be phrased a little bit
differently this would be phrase like
this she was incredibly generous with
her story because she wanted to create
awareness about
things like this happening to people
still today and she wanted people to
know that her family
weren't so different they weren't
foolish they weren't stupid
they loved their kids and they were
taken advantage of by a master
manipulator so we would talk to her
about what their day-to-day life was
like doctor really what music they
listened to what they ate for breakfast
what were some phrases that their
parents would use and there were
nicknames for each other we tried to
incorporate all that into the show so
that when you're watching it you really
have a feeling of context in which this
guy was able to insinuate himself and
like when they are looking at the
newspaper you know she sees a headline
that says woman sees heavy breathing UFO
that is actually a real headline from
the newspaper at the time that she
looked at and there's all these little
details in the show that are real things
that we replicated a lot of the dialogue
is taken from actual transcripts of
phone conversations or core transcripts
so we tried to avoid making it
melodramatic making it uh feel like a
caricature but by being as truthful as
possible
it's a real family
and Jan is still alive I mean she's
she's a producer on the show she was
present
um
Jan's collaboration made it possible to
be authentic to a degree that it never
would have otherwise
so Jan and her family gave us their
childhood Diaries like the actual dies
it gave us clothes that they wore they
give us furniture from their house they
give us thousands of photographs they
give us recordings that they had made of
their own family a bee the Predator we
wanted to portray them faithfully and
respectfully and capture the texture and
fabric of their lives
and he sees these two lights moving
across the field
not headlights they were going too fast
you ever seen a thing like that Jan
well
Never Say Never
one of our biggest fears going into the
show and telling the story was verging
on anything gratuitous or exploitative
the story was about what people didn't
see it's about how they didn't see but I
will never let Bob Burch told anywhere
near me or my family ever again for that
reason we were never going to portray
sexual abuse on screen and we're never
going to ask actors to perform scenes
that might be traumatic or triggering
[Music]
oddly enough it has there's light at the
end of the tunnel at the end of the
story you know the family survived and
one of the most important things I think
about the story and one of the things we
talked about in The Writer's room all
the time is that the same values that
allowed them to be exploited
um also help them survive
my intention is not to tell a story that
says don't trust anyone to live your
life in paranoia just listen to your
instincts
gonna head back to the store for the
afternoon
I'll see you tonight
we can't tell tell anyone
anyone about Zeta or sethra or their
people
do you understand
I think there are a lot of things that
viewers can learn from the show I mean
one is to to be vigilant and as Jan says
you know listen to the the first voice
in your head that says
um something seems off about this as
opposed to the second voice which says
no no it couldn't possibly be you know
it's easy to judge people it's harder
but more important to
understand what they went through and
how something that seems Unthinkable
could have happened
I think when whenever you're telling a
true story and this story in particular
I think it's really important to bring
your empathy to it and
um and and to understand what it really
felt like to live it and as a writer as
a as an audience member as an actor we
always I think need to to bring your
empathy the flyer just to give you a
little beak give me a little big even
when you are portraying a person who
does evil things you have to look at
them as a human being when you sit down
to write them on the page it doesn't
mean you have to have sympathy for them
but uh empathy is the muscle that you
have to use as a writer and I think
probably as an actor as any sort of
creative person when you're telling the
story and trying to create a believable
character
the degree to which you get seduced as a
viewer by B is a testament to a how
seductive and Charming he really was
because everything that we've written
and portrayed is something that he did
and something that happened and a
testament to Jake Lacy's performance
because he's so Charming is so likable
and he's so authentic in his his
portrayal even if you know that he's a
monster you still feel his
intentionality you feel him you feel
that he wants what he wants and
he is so good at constructing the mask
that he almost feels
relatable if you forget what it is he
wants and then you remember he's a
monster in terms of the writer's room or
the conversations with Jake there's no
attempt to make him sympathetic
he is
a sociopath and a pedophile and uh in
the sense that you know evil is as evil
does he's evil
um I don't believe in black and white
evil but he's about as close to evil as
you can even get
[Music]
foreign
the family has been part of the process
from the beginning and so it was really
scary to show it to them for the first
time and it was tremendously
tremendously gratifying huge relief that
they were proud of it they felt that we
had we had captured their lives and
their experience
when Jan watched the show that was a
really meaningful moment for me for us
she grabbed my hand and said you know
it's okay it's it's it's good like a
little way into it and we finished my
heart was beating and
we gave each other a hug and I felt like
you know we had uh we had
done what we set out to do
for her to recognize her childhood and
her experience and her family
in what we had put on screen
[Music]